Prefixes.
Prefixes are added to the beginning of a base word.
For example, the word "repaint."
"Paint" is the base word, "re" in the beginning is the prefix.
Prefixes change the meaning of the word that it's added to.
For example, when I add "re" to a word, it means to do again,...
...like when I say "repaint" or "reread" or "rewrite."
Reheat.
All these words means to "do again," so paint again, read again,...
...write again or heat it again.
When I add the prefix "un" to a word, it means "not,"...
...like if I say "unhappy," that means not happy.
"Unfair" means it is not fair.
"Unlock" means don't lock it.
When I add the prefix "pre" to a word, it means "before."
For example, when I say "preview," it means to view it before...
...or see it or look at it before.
When I say "precook," it means to cook it beforehand.
When I add the prefix "mis" to a word, it means "wrong."
So the word "misspell" means that it was spelled wrong or incorrectly.
The word "misunderstood" means that they were understood the wrong way.
When I add the prefix "dis" to a word, it means "opposite of."
For example, if I say "dislike," that is the opposite of the word "like."
If I say "disagree," that is the opposite of the word "agree,"...
...which means they don't agree.
Now you know how important prefixes are...
...and how they can change the meaning of the entire word.